outside the baby's home of Carlos kun a
car arrives is not clear if the former
Nissan Chairman is inside he's denied
fleeing justice insisting he's escaped
injustice after leaving Japan where he
was being held on charges of financial
misconduct he said in a statement I am
now in Lebanon and will no longer be
held hostage by a rigged Japanese
justice system where guilt is presumed
discrimination is rampant and basic
human rights are denied the 65 year olds
are brought departure will raise
questions given his bail conditions
banned him from traveling overseas his
lawyer said he was stunned and denied
any involvement or knowledge of the
escape he insists lawyers have all three
of goons passports although I'm about
good he still thought I was very
surprised by the news and if there is
important information that comes through
I will contact the court and if this is
true and we can't help but think that it
violates the bail conditions the
businessman turned around the fortunes
of French carmaker Renault gaining the
nickname
Lacoste killer he presided over an
alliance with Nissan reviving the ailing
brand but it all unraveled when he was
arrested in Tokyo accused of
understating his salary transferring
personal financial losses to his
employer and diverting Nissan money to
enrich himself since his arrest late
last year mr. goon has always maintained
his innocence claiming he is the victim
of a boardroom coup he was due to face
trial in April but Japan does not have
an extradition agreement with Lebanon
and it's unclear what steps the
authority might no take to bring him
back
Cohen is expected to hold a press
conference
the next few days Jenny Longden Sky News